Then I jumped in my rental car, called my
mom, and then crashed into you.
Thank God.
"That's not your dad in the picture.
I did buy ecstasy from him, though.
Yum." She sounds fun.
She is.
Oh, God, that's so great.
He's not my dad.
It's just another great guy that I ran away
from because I'm a complete mess.
Who?
When you were little, who did you picture
when you were imagining him?
Bryan Cranston from Malcolm in the Middle.
Not Breaking Bad.
I couldn't even watch that. I didn't want to
see my dad cooking meth.
For me, it was Bob Barker.
I always dreamed that one day he'd pull up
outside my school and we'd go spay and neuter
pets together.
Yeah.
So you don't know your dad either?
Actually, now I do.
A great friend of mine lost his father a
while back, and so I decided to track down my
own before it was too late.
Did you ever think about finding yours?
Of course. But then I worry that he's going
to be a criminal or a drunk or a prop comic.
Eww.
And then other times I think that he would be
everything that's ever been missing from my
life and completely transform me into the
best version of myself that I could be.
Fix your abandonment issues, your commitment
issues.
You're not seeing women as human being
Did your dad do all of that for you?
Ha, No.
Actually, a few years back, a really amazing
girl came into my life.
My daughter, Ellie.
She is the best thing that ever happened to
an idiot like me.
The moment I saw her, I knew I had to
change.
Don't get me wrong.
My dad is great.
He's kind and funny.
And watching the two of them together, it
just.
You got it. Yeah.
Look, if you ever do decide to track down
your dad.
It probably won't fix all your problems.
But if you get lucky like I did, it'd be
great.
So was my story juicy enough for you, or are
you going to make me pay?
You're off the hook.
You don't have to venmo me anything.
Or as my past self used to say, you don't
have to "VenmoHoe" me.
I said past self.